they have the most unappreciated
unforgiving job they're the ones out
there two o'clock in the morning trying
to fix an engine hanging over the side
of an aircraft carrier so that jet is on
the flat schedule the next day really
underappreciated the amount of work and
how important that work was and I wanted
to understand that so I could help
Advocate to get them the things that
needed to be successful and the only way
to do that is to know what they were
going through so I went through the
entire process to get certified to learn
about that it also is a great way to get
to know the Marines extremely well but
being a brown shirt being a crew chief
of a plane captain on a carrier man
those young kids are putting in just the
most ridiculous hours doing the hardest
job in the world with almost no thanks
no appreciation at all because what they
need is to get a jet to make the flight
schedule and then you know Dave Burke
mans up the Jet and gets all the glory
because he launches off the carries out
for a 45-minute air-conditioned flight
totally comes back lands it turns the
keys over and say Here's my rental